kennt ihr die größte schule der welt
oder in deutschland sagen wir mal in
deutschland dann schreibt schreibt doch
mal gerne in die kommentare schreiben
jetzt in die kommentare
wie viele leute sind auf der schule auch
die ihr geht das interessiert mich mal
gut dann habt ihr es genug gewartet
jetzt ist es so weit wir kommen zum
schlechtesten zeugnis dass ich hier
gesehen habt also ich habe erst einmal
den durchschnitt ausgerechnet war glaube
ich 5,5 was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
man das ist wirklich um spontan dass ich
das video heute drehen
ihr habt ihr schon gelesen es geht um
zeugnisse ich glaube die gab es letzte
woche freitag ich bin ja nicht mehr so
wirklich in der materie da ich nehme
hier zur schule gehen zumindest in
vielen bundesländern gab es zeugnisse
das habe ich dann gemerkt weil mir viele
leute geschrieben haben ja alex wann
kommt denn das nächste zeugnis wie du
kannst du dich bitte mal auf einen
scheißtag ist reagieren kukksi an weil
es ist so interessant und ich habe im
durchschnitt von 17
das problem warum ich solche zeugnis
videos eigentlich nicht mehr machen
wollte war weil wir irgendwie alles
schon mal hatten und es gibt nichts
neues
und das wird so ein bisschen langweilig
deswegen habe ich gedacht es auf das war
es jetzt fertig aus aber dann haben wir
wirklich viele von euch geschrieben dass
ich das doch bitte noch mal machen soll
ich bin die ganze zeugnisse
durchgegangen und ich habe noch ein paar
gefunden
die wirklich außergewöhnlich sind und
die ich vorher so noch nie gesehen haben
deswegen gibt es jetzt noch ein paar
davon
und ich würde sagen wir gar nicht lange
fangen direkt mal an ich kann euch eine
sache schon mal vorweg sagen heute haben
wir wirklich das schlechteste zeugnis
ich habe bestimmt jetzt schon 56 davon
gemacht das schlechteste das ich je
gesehen habe
also wie sowas zustande kommt ich habe
keine ahnung da werden weil gleich mal
ein bisschen genauer darauf eingehen
ich würde sagen wir fangen an und ich
bin gespannt ich hab so ich glaube ich
habe insgesamt sieben rausgesucht die
anderen waren halt also das sind mit
abstand die interessantesten das erste
zeugnis das mich erreicht hat also da
muss ich sagen da war jemand sehr sehr
unzufrieden das hat sie glaube ich auch
dazu geschrieben ich kann es euch immer
zeigen das war es jetzt komplett obwohl
ich weiß gar nicht ob es einen sieg oder
ein erbe ich glaube aber sie und zwar in
die noten das ist jetzt jetzt nichts
mehr geschenkt ist natürlich auch nicht
gut wir haben in mathe sondern sechs
habe ich gerade gesehen aber das ist
erst mal gerade dann haben wir noch 88
versöhnten
davon allein schuldig 55 und angaben zum
arbeits und sozialverhalten ist annegret
muss pünktlich zum unterricht erscheinen
23 verspätungen sie muss lernen sich in
wortwahl und ton angemessen zu verhalten
und da muss ich ehrlich sein ich hatte
in meiner gesamten schullaufbahn nicht
eine person die so was auch im zeugnis
stehen hatte das dass sie halt wirklich
oder das anscheinend auch noch
mitgezählt wurde wie oft die person zu
spät kam bei uns waren es zum beispiel
nicht so dass ich mein mann kam auch mal
zu spät ich würde sagen in meiner
abiturzeit war ich auch bestimmt 20 mal
zu spät so weil man kommt dann halt fünf
minuten zu spät weil man das ist auch
irgendwann nicht mehr so ernst wie
früher aber dass die lehrer dann
wirklich mit zählen ohne 23
draufschreiben ja ist mir neu
also das ist ja 88 versäumte stunden
tage an denen du halt also nicht da war
und bis dann noch 23 mal zu spät
gekommen also könnte man eigentlich
zusammenfassen von der zeit die du da
warst bist du fast immer zu spät
gekommen
ich meine wenn man halt nicht gerne für
aufstellt dann ist das eben so dann
sollten die lehrer das auch akzeptiert
heute machen wir weiter und kommen zum
nächsten
dass ich so noch nicht gesehen habe also
ich hab ihn bestimmt jetzt insgesamt
schon über 1000 zeugen von euch
angeschaut aber so was war noch nicht
dabei und zwar sieht das so aus
und oben drüber steht so in der
konferenz am 5 2 2009 10 sind folgende
leistungen festgestellt worden
man muss sich vorstellen oder so ein
großer konferenzraum die lehrer alle so
am grübeln was kriegt denn jetzt die
schülerin die hat die sich in englisch
geschlagen wie in mathe wie in physik
und irgendwann ist dann aber so die luft
raus in dieser konferenz und die sagen
sich ach ich meine wir sitzen jetzt
schon so lange hier lass uns doch
einfach überall guten schreiben ich
meine da wird sich ja wohl keiner
beschweren oder dann haben wir heute
endlich feierabend und ich glaube so
haben die das dann auch gemacht wir
haben hier ja zwölf fächer die einfach
alle mit gut bestanden wurde also mit
einer 2 und ich weiß nicht aber
irgendwie wirkt das für mich so ein
bisschen komisch ist natürlich
wahrscheinlich ein sehr großer zufall
das ist schon ein gewaltiger zufall so
wir können sehr gerne mal die
wahrscheinlichkeit ausrechnen dass ein
zeugnis so ausfällt ich meine wir haben
jetzt zwölf verschiedene fächer in jedem
fach gibt es sechs verschiedene noten
also von 1 bis 6 wir haben jetzt zwölf
mal nehmen
eigentlich hatte man das war zwölf mal
zwölf also zwölf hoch 6 wenn ich jetzt
richtig kriege falls nicht korrigiert
mich bitte gleich eins zu obwohl das
kann nicht sein
wir lassen das ganze zurück na ja aber
ich kann sagen das hat mich wirklich
schon fand ich krass dass das halt also
ich sag mal so es ist herausgestochen
und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch mithin
die folge gewinnen und kommen wir zum
nächsten zeugnis diese noten habe ich so
noch nicht gesehen und zwar steht vor
jeder note irgendwie so bei uns war das
im fußball immer so man kann halt so
erst in die f jugend e jugend der jugend
c jugend und ich wollte auch mal in der
er 13 war ich auch kurze 2 war ich auch
keine ahnung für das steht habe ich so
vorher noch nie gesehen deswegen falls
ihr das wisst schreibt es sehr gerne in
die kommentare rein was ich dann aber
wirklich toll fand bei den bemerkungen
du hast das amt der unesco schülerin
übernommen es ist wahrscheinlich dass
man posten wenn man so wie schule
vertreten musste im hinsicht auf
wohltätigkeitsorganisation hilfe und
sowas macht sich auf den zeugen ist
natürlich immer gut ja ich meine ich war
auch lange zeit in der schülervertretung
komischerweise haben sie das bei mir
immer vergessen also dass schon bei mir
nie drauf ich musste dann immer zum
sekretariat gehen dann habe ich ein
neues zeugnis gekriegt das war bestimmt
fünfmal so machen weiter mit dem zeugnis
von julia julia geht in die siebte
klasse
und wenn man sich das zeugnis so
anschaut überhaupt in europa fünf
geschichte 5 war gut aber da habe ich
gar nicht drauf ankommt ich gucke mir
generell dann kaum noch die noten haben
einfach weil das so wahnsinnig werden
alles schon mal und das lustigste sind
dann meistens nur bemerkungen oder
irgendwas anderes und was wir über ihn
direkt aufgefallen ist klasse 7 l
ich habe mir dann so gestern einen
zeugen ist nach dem anderen anguckt dann
habe ich so diese 7l gelesen sagt auf
dem bett und b c d e f g h i j k
wie groß die neue schule also mindestens
zwölf klassen pro jahrgang ich glaube
das weiß eine realschule das heißt wir
haben sechs jahre auf eine realschule
mal zwölf klassen mal 25 schüler gleich
ach das geht ja sogar na ja auf jeden
fall habe ich noch nie von der klasse
gehört die irgendwie was mit elvis kennt
ihr die größte schule der welt oder in
deutschland sagen wir mal in deutschland
dann schreibt schreib doch mal gerne in
die kommentare schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
wie ich viele leute sind auf der schule
auf die ihr geht
das interessiert mich mal auf meiner
waren 2000 also wirklich so ungefähr 900
eigentlich genau 1000 gut machen wir
weiter mit michael der hat mir auch eben
sein zeugnis darüber gemeldet und so
stand dann auch wieder so ein schöner
text dabei der unruhige schüler folgte
dem unterricht nicht immer mit der
nötigen konzentration und ausdauer
er liest sich leicht ablenken und
schwitzte gerne mündlich arbeitete er
gute berufliche aufgaben erstellte
michael flott und selbstständig die
äußere form ließ zunehmend zu wünschen
übrig also michael in zukunft ein
bisschen mehr konzentrieren
das habe ich jetzt eigentlich nur aus
dem folgenden grund mit reingenommen und
zwar michael namen einfach tastschreiben
mit google erfolgt teilt ich denke mir
so alter könnt ihr euch nicht mehr
modernen namen überlegen für
irgendwelche fischer auch wenn ich das
lese werken und gestalten in welchem
jahrhundert leben wir dass ich das hier
ist wahrscheinlich bei meiner oma schon
so und tastschreiben stelle ich mir zeit
vor mit der tastatur am pc schreiben ich
weiß nicht ob ihr versteht was ich meine
aber halt dieses sehr sehr altmodische
genauso wie werden zum beispiel das fach
musik
jetzt fällt mir kein name ein musizieren
heißt oder so
na ja ich weiß nicht vielleicht auch ein
schlechtes beispiel gut dann habt ihr
jetzt genug gewartet jetzt ist es so
weit wir kommen zum schlechtesten
zeugnis das ich je gesehen habe also ich
habe es damals in deutschland
ausgerechnet war glaube ich 5,5 hat das
ist ja fast der hälfte fünf hälfte sechs
wie so etwas geht weiß ich nicht weil
meistens ist es ja so wenn personen
wirklich solche schlechten noten kriegen
dann liegt es daran weil die die meiste
zeit überhaupt gar nicht da waren aber
wie man dann wirklich in jedem fach so
scheiße sein kann auch im sport ja ich
meine den sport kommt auch jeder
irgendwie auch ne 4 wenn man sich ein
bisschen mehr gibt eigentlich sogar auf
eine 3 ist für mich wirklich ein sehr
großes rätsel also da hat man auch
schule dann wirklich null wir haben erst
mal versonnen bestimmten 235 davon
unentschuldigt 217 gut damit geht es
natürlich los mann war schon ein drittel
der zeit nicht da trotzdem wurde es ja
irgendwie bewertet also ihr könnt ja
sehen ich glaube die fächer muss ich gar
nicht vorlesen haben über eine 5 außer
in musik da haben wir sogar eine 6 ja
wie das geht keine ahnung geschichte
sechs erdkunde 666 sport sechs ja dann
warst du da wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
aber dann steht da ja eigentlich nicht
bewerb war und dann steht unten noch
liebt über nicht ausreichende leistungen
könnten die versetzung gefährdet leute
also ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen
soll
das habe ich von jemandem bekommen der
dazugeschrieben bach bitte den namen
werk das ist von einem mädchen aus der
stufe über uns und sie ist auch noch
stolz so gut ob das stimmt weiß ich
nicht
können wir sehr gerne eure meinung in
die kommentare schreiben habt ihr jemals
so ein schlechtes zeugnis gesehen ich
definitiv nicht und ich glaube ich habe
schon sehr viele gesehen
von daher war es das mit dem video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen gern
daumen nach oben da passt scho auch in
der schule seit verwendet das dahinter
ich habe im durchschnitt habe von 2,52
command ich glaube das sollte jeder
irgendwie schaffen wenn man sich ein
bisschen mehr gibt das war von mir
checkt instagram gibt es jetzt jeden tag
ein foto hat rein